[Musique]
Chantal Hébert Michel David à la
question gay bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir je
vous le dis tout de suite je vais devoir
vous bousculer des casesb parce que le
Grand Jury a recommandé des accusations
qu'on donne en train par hasard ça nous
tombe dessus à l'instant mais d'abord
parce que à Z pas tout à fait là
je disais en tout début d'émission
qu'on pourrait se gratter la tête en
écoutant la période des questions je dis
quand même une réforme sérieuse là il y
a 3000 articles 300 pages peu importe et
on a eu l'impression de d'un peu d'un
cirque à la période des questions que et
c'est rare que je parle d'autant de
l'opposition de mon impression que on
n'avait pas mesuré l'importance de cette
réforme là où on était allé vite dans
les conclusions vous me direz si vous
êtes d'accord ou pas on écoute gabrenado
Dubois monsieur Legault monsieur Tanguy
monsieur le groupe on vient tout de
suite
le Premier ministre vient de se
féliciter
d'accomplir
moi aussi je veux dire un mot anglais le
web Dream de Gaëtan barrette il vient de
me dire moi je vais aller jusqu'au
Gaëtan barrette et jamais allé d'abord
le coût chef de Québec soldats devrait
se rappeler qui puent un chef étudiant
mais qui était à l'Assemblée nationale
ici dans les mots qui choisis là qui
vieillissent un petit peu qui prennent
un petit peu de maturité
ce qui reste au ministre ce sera la
capacité de blanc mais et de congédier
alors après le super ministre d'économie
le conseiller numérique on a le
mini-ministre de la santé madame la
Présidente ce qu'on voit depuis hier
c'est que les oppositions et les
syndicats des femmes de statu quo
défendent le passé
et pourtant avec ce qui est proposé par
le ministre de la Santé ce qu'on vit
c'est une meilleure organisation du
travail
chacun son rôle dans l'ajout de
parlementaire bien sûr mais d'abord
premier commentaire sur tout ça
j'entends
c'est rapide et le ton est pas
prometteur si on commence braquer et moi
je prends au sérieux le projet de loi
qui a été présenté en présentant un
projet de loi de cet envergure là si on
n'a pas des intentions sérieuses et le
ton du débat à l'Assemblée nationale
reflète pas le sérieux de la question et
cela malgré le fait qu'il y a au Québec
un consensus politique sur la nécessité
de faire une réforme
Michel David moi j'ai eu je vous le dis
comme je le comme je le parle je regarde
ça tout à l'heure j'ai eu l'impression
que l'opposition avait comme raté un
rendez-vous là je suis pas en train de
dire faut qu'il soit d'accord avec le
projet de loi mais dans le ton dans la
complexité de la réponse les Québécois
écoute ça ils disaient bon ça mais
corrigez-moi ou ajouter ce que vous
voulez
le temps évidemment était pas très
relevé mais on s'est concentré sur le
plus facile je peux dire à une nouvelle
structure encore de la bureaucratie ça
une réforme à la barrette ça c'est c'est
très facile de dire ça et évidemment ça
a des échos d'un population qui se dit
ah non pas encore mais sur le fond il y
a beaucoup de choses à dire de cette de
cette réforme là est-ce que par exemple
l'opposition est d'accord avec la
réduction vraiment énorme des
accréditations syndicales qui va
permettre une mobilité à se dire oui de
mobilité en général c'est à l'ensemble
du Québec l'ancienneté est-ce qu'ils
sont d'accord avec ça ou non est-ce
qu'ils sont d'accord pour trouver un
moyen de faire travailler les
spécialistes un peu plus en région puis
un peu plus à des heures moins
favorables on sait pas ce qui pense de
ça alors je pense que ils vont devoir
refaire leur devoirs et
retourner à l'Assemblée nationale avec
un peu plus de substance
c'est comme si les parties d'opposition
étaient partis plus vite que les propres
leurs propres syndicats leur propre
allié d'habituellement dans le réseau de
la santé qui sont beaucoup plus
circonspects qui font beaucoup plus
attention à leur réaction que ce soit la
fille que ce soit la CSN bon la FM
excuse est contenté les médecins
spécialistes de communiquer on n'a pas
encore fait pour être presse on étudie
le projet de loi parce qu'ils savent
eux-mêmes parce qu'ils ont les codes de
leurs membres parce que moi j'en reçois
des courriels à l'émission des auditeurs
des infirmières des préposés
bénéficiaires des médecins il y a
beaucoup plus de curiosité que
d'inquiétude actuellement autour du
projet de loi on se demande est-ce que
ça pourrait pas améliorer les choses
est-ce que c'est pas une mauvaise idée
la mobilité par exemple les infirmières
il y en a beaucoup qui le demandent
depuis très longtemps syndicalement
c'est pas populaire mais les membres
aiment ça l'idée de pouvoir se promener
sans perdre leur ancienneté alors on est
en train de juger où on peut attaquer le
projet de loi qu'est-ce qui peut être
modifié alors que les parties de
position eux ont pris le projet de loi
dont j'étais à la poubelle on dit rien
de bon là-dedans ils partez peut-être
partir la guerre trop vite parce que
visiblement je pense que c'est pas
encore clair à savoir comment elle va
être reçu véritablement dans le réseau
de la santé cette réforme là mais encore
une fois ils ont le droit s'ils jugent
que c'est le cas d'aller à la gare
contre un élément un autre mais là on a
l'impression que c'est à celui qui va
trouver l'expression la plus suave la
plus drôle on est quand même devant une
réforme importante et c'est sérieux là
les gens se font opérer au privé les
gens ont pas dermatologue les gens
arrivent attendre avec leur mère de 90
ans l'urgent c'est sérieux c'est ça
j'avais l'impression que le sérieux
Chantal de l'opération a été passée à la
trappe d'abord pour faire écho est-ce
qu'avec bien dire j'avais un rendez-vous
médical mais aujourd'hui et pour une
rare fois dans ma vie la première chose
qui est arrivé la première question
portait sur ce que je trouve dans la vie
plutôt que ce que je ressens et et
c'était pas une discussion hostile le
gouvernement a tort c'était
l'intérêt de réfléchir
l'opposition est pas là pour avaliser
tout ce que fait le gouvernement mais un
c'est un immense chantier 2 c'est une
grande discussion dans laquelle
l'opposition peut jouer un rôle
constructif et trois
le gouvernement est en place pour 4 ans
il vient d'être élu alors peut-être que
tu es son projet de réforme dans l'oeuf
avec des grands effets de tâches c'est
c'est pas nécessairement le moment
un extrait de monsieur Legault que je
vous envoie sur parce que là ça
s'amusant parce que des gens disent vous
voulez recentraliser effectivement on
entend ça puis d'autres disent non on
décentralise au contrat parce que on dit
quelque chose de son contraire bon ça
peut être résolu monsieur Legault
essayait de résoudre cette année mon
écoute
la bonne gestion là c'est Quebec la
haute direction évalue le résultat mais
laisse le choix des moyens localement
puis là ça leur donne la corde ils
peuvent se prendre avec mais ils ont une
obligation de résultats de donner des
bons services de qualité merci
Michel David je commence avec vous cette
fois-ci est-ce que c'est une ce qu'on
peut répondre à cette question est-ce
que c'est une décentralisation ou une
centralisation je pense que les deux en
même temps c'est certain que quand on
regarde la jungle qui va être
l'employeur unique alors que jusqu'à
présent c'était les 6 lieux qui
employaient
les gens dans leur région dans leur
secteur là on peut dire bon ça c'est de
la centralisation mais l'important je
pense pour la bonne impérative les
bonnes opérations dans le réseau c'est
qu'est-ce que les gens sur le terrain
vont être capables de faire de plus par
rapport à ce qui pouvait pas faire avant
là on le sait depuis la réforme barrette
il y avait plein d'établissements où il
y avait pas de direction on se reportait
quand il y avait un problème qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire et on demandait aussi
puis aussi là il va avoir partout des
gens qui et c'est là que ça va ça va se
jouer quelle latitude ils vont avoir
exactement est-ce qu'il va monsieur Lego
ils y vont avoir à cette corde pour se
pendre mais concrètement quels sont les
pouvoirs la marge de décision qui vont
avoir c'est là qu'on va voir s'il y a
vraiment des centralisation d'ailleurs
je sais pas ce qu'il y avait à Québec
aujourd'hui des images
rocambolesques
aujourd'hui là même monsieur Legault
avec la pente des hommes bref allez
centralisation des centralisations c'est
les deux comme dit Michel ça qui est
intéressant
je pensais que j'aime beaucoup moi non
plus l'image de François Legault sur la
pendaison
comme ça parle sans trop réfléchir à ce
qu'il dit pour ceux qui mettent de
l'huile sur le feu comme ça au début de
la réflexion autour de son projet de loi
est une bonne idée mais bon on commence
à connaître la personnage des fois il y
a un échappe un peu je pense certains
que j'aime cette idée-là mais l'empêche
que c'est vrai qu'il faut donner de la
marge de manœuvre localement pour la
gestion des horaires pour être capable
de modifier des choses mais jusqu'où ça
va aller Michel a raison par exemple
parce que les les directeurs
d'établissement vont pouvoir choisir
d'innover d'une manière ou d'une autre
choisir la les appareils médical qui
vont pouvoir par exemple l'acheter en
disant moi c'est là que je vais mettre
l'accent pour améliorer les temps
d'attente à jour où est-ce que tout ça
va être décidé en haut lieu qu'on va
juste avoir quelqu'un qui va désigner
coupable quand ça va mal parce que ça ça
serait pas une bonne idée de dire on a
un PDG dans un établissement puis quand
ça va mal pouvoir le mettre dehors et
quand ça va bien pour rien décider ça
c'est pas une bonne idée alors là cette
marge de manoeuvre là effectivement
jusqu'au va pouvoir aller et c'est là
que l'opposition je reprends
et peut-être un peu tôt pour en faire le
procès ou deux trouver qu'il y a quelque
chose à redire au fait qu'on n'a pas
encore de réponse
et ce sont toutes des questions
intéressantes à débattre mais on
pourrait croire que les parties au
Québec solidaire mais les libéraux en
tout cas qui se sont essayés et qui
connaissent l'ampleur de la tâche et qui
ont échoué
voudrait quand même laisser le temps au
temps avant de grimper dans les dos
comme un rendez-vous manqué mais ton
mais on va oublier la journée on verra
les prochaines journées mais il y avait
beaucoup de spectacles quand les gens
disent
les périodes des questions les
découragent c'est difficile de pas être
d'accord bon ok PLK rapidement
ils sont quoi 12 ou 14 dans ce comité
ils sont 14 Michel David on va voir les
séances qu'on connaît
l'ancienne éditorialiste chroniqueurs en
chef etc de la presse il a été sénateur
bien sûr des anciens ministres ont
pierre Arcan Louis Charlebois Jean
D'Amour le fils de monsieur Charre est
Antoine John Charrey veut-il un jour lui
être chef ou prof Jeff Kelly alors
est-ce que comment vous avez réagi quand
vous avez appris qu'il y avait un comité
je vous signale que toujours pas de chef
en vue comment vous avez réagi Michel
moi j'ai peur que le parti libérale
réinventent la roue écoutez ça jamais
été un parti très fort sur la réflexion
alors on va se le dire ça fait 20 ans
qu'il survent sur un petit livre que
Jean Charest avait demandé à Claude Ryan
d'écrire il y avait pas eu de réflexion
à l'intérieur du parti autour de ça on a
pris ça on disait ah voilà
le livre le petit livre rouge sur les
valeurs libérales depuis ce temps-là il
y a eu aucun effort de réflexion qui
s'est fait et là il se fait parce que il
y avait juste à dire l'indépendance
c'est dangereux et il gagnait des
élections mais là quel est le projet des
libéraux le pourquoi ils sont là les
libérer le PQ on sait qu'il va le faire
l'indépendance
QS donc ils veulent faire la révolution
socialiste le GO il veut que le Québec
soit aussi riche que l'Ontario les
libéraux qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent on en
a aucune idée et je pense beaucoup
qu'ils vont répondre à cette question-là
ils ont dit déjà comment ça dire on
changera pas nos valeurs puis finalement
ça va être un peu la même chose alors
moi je pense qu'ils ont plutôt intérêt à
se trouver un chef Chantal
il y a cinq provinces au Canada où le
parti libéral
sous une forme ou une autre ne fait plus
partie du paysage et en une sixième
l'Ontario ou le parti le Parti libéral
se cherche et se demande si encore une
place sur l'échiquier politique alors de
se parler entre libéraux de garder ses
valeurs c'est probablement un exercice
qui va faire qu'on parle des libéraux
maintenant mais j'ai de la misère à
avoir une solution là-dedans parce que
le problème c'est qu'on trouve plus la
case dans laquelle ce partie là pourrait
s'inscrire
Alec vous avez une moins d'une minute
sur les libéraux
je pense que André Pratt et certainement
l'un des gardiens du temple approprié
pour faire une réflexion autour des
valeurs libérales
capacité intellectuelle tout à fait
capable de essayer de savoir où on en
est là avec les valeurs libérales
comment les réactualiser mais je note
que dans les poids lourds que vous avez
montré de ce comité-là les petites
photos tout à l'heure parce qu'il y a
aussi des militants militantes moins
connus qui font partie du comité mais on
s'entend que le jour une force de
gravité dans les comités là les poids
lourds que vous voyez vont ceux qui vont
être ceux qui vont beaucoup animer cette
réflexion là il n'y a qu'un qu'une
personne genre d'amour qui vient de
l'extérieur de Montréal la grande région
de Montréal et il n'avait pas les les
mots traitants à l'issue de la dernière
campagne électorale sur la déconnexion
des libéraux en région on espère que
Jean D'Amour pourra se faire entendre
parce que c'est clairement un point
important il est le seul on a représenté
cette vision là on avait préparé un
tableau un petit clin d'oeil sur qui
sera le prochain chef je vous le montre
pour faire sourire parce qu'on le sait
pas là on le sait pas
bon sourire
on se demandait il avait prédit qu'il
allait avoir des accusations contre lui
qui allait arrêter que se passe-t-il
avec Donald Trump et ce grand jury
expliquez-nous voilà donc on vient
d'apprendre ça vient de sortir là le
grand jury de mettre en accusation dans
notre chambre Patrice est très gros ici
c'est la première fois qu'un ancien
président américain puis aussi un
candidat à la présidence de 2024 soit
inculpée de cette façon connaît pas
encore les détails mais ce qu'on sait
c'est que le Grand Jury a voté il faut
une majorité ils sont 23 il faut 12
personnes qui sont en faveur de son
inculpation donc ils ont voté pour
l'inculpé donc à partir de maintenant
dans notre chambre les avocats de dans
notre chambre vont négocier avec New
York et normalement il a déjà dit qu'il
va se rendre à la justice nord-est qui
va se présenter sur les lieux donc ils
vont prendre ces empreintes digitales
cette fameuse photo donc c'est la
première fois donc c'est une assez
grosse nouvelle ici alors je vous
rappelle
la cause c'est l'affaire stromy Daniel
qui remonte à 2016 ou l'avocat de Donald
Trump Michael Cohen avait payé 130 000
dollars à cette jeune femme pour qu'elle
pour qu'elle garde son style elle avait
eu une histoire extraconjugale avec
Donald Trump en 2006 donc ils l'ont payé
dollars pour qu'elle se taisent or ça
c'est légal il peut y avoir un
consentement entre deux adultes sauf que
ils ont prétendu l'administration
l'organisation Trump a prétendu que
c'était des frais juridiques d'une part
mais là où le crime aurait été commis
c'est que normalement ça aurait été sa
campagne électorale pour qu'il soit
président des États-Unis et c'est là
qu'on parle de crime donc le jury
affirme qui est assez de preuves pour
qu'il soit mise en examen donc c'est un
lien il disent c'est une façon que vous
avez le paiement de 130 000 aurait
presque dû puis s'arrêter légal être
considéré comme l'argent électoral parce
que vous êtes servi de ça pour pas que
ça nuise à votre campagne électorale
c'est ça le c'est pour ça qu'on dit que
c'était compliqué c'est ça le le
exactement c'est la loi du financement
en fait de toute campagne électorale aux
États-Unis donc est-ce que il va aller à
New York ce qu'il doit aller est-ce
qu'il y a une heure est-ce qu'on des
menottes c'est à dire que là ils sont en
train de négocier parce qu'il y a toute
une affaire de sécurité on connaît dans
notre chambre il va certainement réagir
facilement et certainement que lui-même
a été pris par surprise parce que
jusqu'à présent c'est dans notre chambre
qui avertissaient les médias à travers
son réseau sociaux pour dire voilà ils
vont m'arrêter c'était arrivé pour les
documents classés même pour New York il
a dit ça y est ils vont m'arrêter donc
là vraiment le grand jury annonça à 17h
un jeudi après-midi donc normalement il
doit il doit se rendre là-bas il a déjà
accepté qu'il allait le faire mais ce
qui est assez incroyable Patrice que
c'est que dans les sondages la cote de
popularité de Donald Trump monte en
flèche il dépasse maintenant un de Satis
de près de 20 points donc très loin
exactement et c'est ce que tous les
experts qui étudient à Trump dans Maggie
il doit en fait trépider de joie presque
ça y est c'est une victime et on s'en
était parlé Patrice cette affaire de
stormy Daniels c'est pas la plus grosse
rien faire si vous voulez quand on
regarde le presque le coup d'État qui a
été formanté le 6 janvier il est accusé
de cela quand même le 6 janvier 2021
également d'avoir gardé les documents
classés secret de les avoir gardés chez
lui à Mara Lago et puis même d'avoir
tenté de renverser les résultats des
élections pensaient qu'il aurait été
inculpées pour ces raisons-là or là
c'est une histoire extraconjugale
Melania venait d'avoir un enfant mais il
a eu cette histoire extra-conjugale avec
stomie Daniels en 2006 il a payé et
c'est ça en fait il devra répondre à ses
accusations là et pour Trump pour lui ça
ne fait que mousser sa popularité
finalement mais il n'est pas condamné là
il faut quand même le dire et beaucoup
de républicains sont pris parce que
certains disent oui mais c'est un c'est
politique là c'est un grand jury
démocratique c'est politique tout ça il
y aurait pas dû être accusé alors là ça
va être intéressant de voir dans le camp
républicain qui va se résolument se
ranger derrière lui ce qui était le cas
avant mais c'était de moins en moins le
cas peut-être ça va redevenir le col
bah oui parce que les sénateurs comme
Lindsay Graham par exemple ou d'autres
sénateurs qui avaient carrément accusé
Harven brag le la personne qui accuse
chambre si vous voulez le ministre de la
justice entre guillemets de l'État de
New York et en fait c'est il était
vraiment accusé par ces gens-là que
c'était une chasse aux sorcières contre
Donald Trump donc ça va être intéressant
de voir comment ils vont
se donne rendez-vous au Téléjournal en
quelques secondes là vous allez ouvrir
notre Téléjournal c'est sûr à 18h alors
à tout de suite puis je dis merci à
Chantal Michel Alec je vous avais dit
bousculé voilà mais c'est intéressant
bientôt au revoir